this make on its own
five-year-olds at barncroft school
listened to their teacher intently
on Wednesday Deborah Piper won't be here
she'll be on the picket line calling for
better conditions for teachers and a pay
rise funded by the government not taken
from her school's budget as it was last
year that comes out of the children's
Pockets that comes out the children's
books so they put us in a very
precarious situation where we feel
really guilty taking the bare minimum as
we have
and putting schools in such dire strait
with budgets so there are two really
good reasons that actually I want to go
on the March and be counties and say
enough more than a hundred thousand
teachers in England and Wales will
strike forcing thousands of schools to
close though some like barncroft will
stay open to look after their most
vulnerable students
last year teachers protested not only
overpay but staff shortages as a third
quit the profession within five years of
qualifying
the unions complain the government is
not engaging with the issues but critics
argue teachers are asking for too much a
12 pay rise which is above inflation my
concern is that by striking overpay when
teachers are relative to the families
that they serve in their school they're
relatively very well paid My worry is
that we're going to go from teaching
being respected and trusted profession
to one where people are less trusting of
what teachers say and do
but head teacher Tracy Griffith explains
that action is about so much more than
money in this country people can only
strike for certain reasons and pay is
one of them
um I think if you were to ask the
majority of teachers in this country
um they would say they were striking for
pay but more importantly for um funding
for schools because they are at the
front line seeing the cuts and
what they're having to deal with without
enough money to do it teachers joining
the strikes Marx and escalation in a
winter of industrial action across the
UK but so far the government has made it
clear it's not prepared to reopen talks
overpay children like these are still
catching up on learning loss during the
covert pandemic and with four days of
strikes planned ahead it is the children
that will suffer Charlie Angela Al
Jazeera London